that Pine of mocha almond fudge you
still have
it the
what hello dark roast my old
friend drop that spoon Billy
Holiday I've kept you caffeine free for
2 hours you're not folding
now get away from me you lame and Ur
wearing
monster I'll drop it I swear no you
won't you don't have the guts you know
me too well
out of my way I got a monkey on my back
named Juan
[Applause]
Valdez don't worry kids on the right up
to Vermont I'll have him in a dog
carrier with a chew
toy by the way what's going on here I'm
sensing a mood well he thinks I'm taking
advantage of save it honey we'll crack
it open later when we're desperate
remember Let each gesture tell a little
story the way she does okay I'll never
be like her well of course not she's one
of the great artists of all time but
we're not gonna honor her by quitting
okay now come on let's go again okay
five six seven eight Oops I did it again
I played with your heart got lost in the
game oh baby baby yes is totally
it so good I can actually feel the
spirit of Britney in the room and you
were not that
innocent
I made these kebabs for Grace once she
totally fell in love with the recipe
liar how could I fall in love with your
kebabs I've never had
them Diane had your kebabs but
apparently I wasn't good enough for your
kebabs wait why do you care that Dian
had Will's kebabs but you don't care
that she's had mine and I've had hers
silly Diana's a girl girl she doesn't
have kebabs she has a
cajina and nice
[Applause]
petits you know Grace I was with Diane a
year and a half it wasn't just one
drunken night in a dorm room it was a
lot of drunken
nights including one embarrassing
incident involving a public bathroom and
an untimely entrance by Ed
cotch by the way I know it seems like I
need to drink in order to have sex I
don't it just makes it
better nobody finds you
interesting except your husband and your
best
friend hey hey hey
hey well hey I've got an idea I'm going
to the Barney sale with Rosario this
weekend why don't you just come
along well I'll need a little money from
the
ATM denied denied
approved Hey where's my best girl
here
gay ferrets to the waiting area gay
ferrets to the waiting
area how is you what's going on what
time did you guys get here why is no one
talking would you calm down don't tell
me to calm down Stan Walker is like a
father to me if anything ever happened
to him I I don't know what I man there
are some really hot doctors in
here
hey then to set Karen w Walker I know
Mrs Walker Oh yeah I remember you Stan
and I met you at the Whitney opening you
were the
[Applause]
bartender no you just gave me your drink
order yeah and I'm still waiting for
it well I'm out of here oh honey will
you pop a stamp on this and drop it in
the mail for me
[Applause]
I like
you hey friends lovers mothers and other
strangers you're never going to believe
what happened to me oh my gosh did you
see that I almost did it half Nelson I
almost Bru my delicates my delicates my
Domo orato Mr
tomatoes
huge news I have met are you ready for
this Mr right well Mr right now anyway
but I'm bu good night folks I'm here all
week Jack
2000 he works over at the jum job you
know that coffee shop in 72nd and his
name is Paul and he is cute with a
capital Q and the busier he gets the
hotter he gets and the hotter he gets
the sweater he gets and the sweater he
gets I forgot where I'm going with this
but the point
is me like he and he like me and the
best part is Shazam he gives me free ice
coffee every time I go in which is every
hour on the hour thank you very much and
occasionally on the half hour
stop I better get going it was great
meeting you hey I'll walk you
out bye
bye she seems
nice you must be
[Applause]
dying aren't you you
dying your husband is going to Guatemala
with
that I would
die I know that bod she could be in a
white snake
video just
die that is some lucky flesh eating
virus that gets
her Jackie pay they could still happen
the next guy you see could turn out to
be Mr right well well
well or maybe
not whyever Taran Walker just breaks my
heart that you don't have a partner for
the spotlight dance however will you
lead it without a
partner Such a Pity a bottle of rum
can't
walls
actually I do have a date yes I was just
on my way to meet him by the punch bowl
or as you would call it the swimming
hole so he's leaving the life he's
come to
know he said he's
leaving
leaving on that Midnight Train to George
leaving on the midnight train that's
right y'all uhhuh said he's going back
to
find going back to find simp love place
and time takes that ride guess who's
going to be right by her side I'll
be I know you will all that Midnight
Train
[Music]
Georgia I'd rather live in his world
live without him
[Music]
my I've got to go I've got to go I've
got to go I've got to
go hey what's up
honey we talked about this
blouse Karen honey what's going on
here I mean i' I found some really cute
outfits here I wear them to work and you
tell me how much you hate
them honey what's going on what's
happening what's all this
about what's this what are you doing
who's that supposed to
[Applause]
[Music]
be hey that's annoying hang on let me
just get this
[Music]
up be a little
awkward been a long time since I slow
danced with a
cop who gun is poking me in the
back I
hope can't believe I'm at a public pool
why doesn't somebody just pee directly
on
me well well
well nice of you to show the race ended
a half hour ago Mason paged me cuz you
weren't here Mrs Walker Cheryl Bricker
fosberg Taylor and Hayden's
mom I have no idea what you just
said I just want you to know I think
you're awful your son Mason swam is hard
out today and all he wanted to do was
share that Joy with his family but when
he looked up in the bleachers for a
familiar face nothing not even been a
housekeeper I find that appalling oh
yeah well I find stretch pants appalling
but I'm too much of a lady to mention it
fat
ass I um do not have a
gri glitter related
injury something much more
hideous
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what happened to your eyebrow
honey you should
ask during the fire I singed it
off you mean singed no actually I mean
singed as the set burned around me I
refused to stop singing my patriotic
finale You're a grand old
when I went to salute I didn't
realize my sleeve was on
fire no all right it is me but it's not
what you think really cuz I think it's
you and a maid's uniform whipping some
old guy in a onesie Am I
Wrong come on it's just a little fetish
film oh my God how did this thing get
into
circulation oh my
God this is the end of me I don't think
I can go on Caren what are you do stop
me Ken don't be ridiculous there we go
nice and
cold
[Applause]
oh boy just one question is dirty little
pig boy the other white
meat come on spill it well I was just
out of college I was broke it's the
oldest story in the world boy me Meets
Girl boy wants girl to do dominatrix
film girl says naked boy says yeah girl
says forget it boy says okay then just
wear this rubber dress and beat the old
guy with a scrub brush girl says how
hard okay Jack since your opponent broke
down while spelling
disinherited if you get this right you
will be our champion the word is matred
oo
uh that's not a gay word of a roller
disco nature
d m
a m a
o
M
A do you know what it
is um oh uh excuse me
waiter I would like some
tea
it wait a minute Karen those almost D
like
letters I'm sorry hag number 12 you're
going to have to leave
no M AI t hey get your paws off of me
who do you think you
are m a i t r e an m
e a m a i t o
[Music]
g would you keep her out of here no Jack
without my help this could end in a
catastroph
apostrophe
um I've kept this from you for a long
time and and that's wrong because it
makes it seem like I'm ashamed of
something I'm not ashamed
of I want I want you to know who I am
because I'm proud of who I
am
Mom are you wearing Chloe Jack
Mom I'm
gay
oh
Judith it's
okay so he's
gay he's still the same little boy who
gave you highlights for the first
time honey I think you're missing the
Silver Lining here when you're old and
in diapers a gay son will know how to
keep you away from chiffon and
[Applause]
backlighting Mom I'm sorry to disappoint
you but this is who I
am you could never disappoint
me I just want you to be
happy looking back on it there have been
[Laughter]
Clues when you were a child you were
overly fond of the nursery rhyme rub a
dub dub three men in a
tub and you do have a lot of
flamboyantly gay
friends I mean look at
will okay Miss Adler this is nurse
trainy Pitman she'll be taking your
blood I like your
hair whoa whoa her is isn't isn't there
someone else who is a little more
experienced someone who didn't drive in
on a big
wheel oh I don't drive it keep taking
the chest over and over again but I'm
all this is
hard now I don't want you to worry
because the nurse Pitman is one of our
finest trainees and I'm going to be here
with you the whole
time sweet my new Jag's
here don't worry ma'am I've done this
Bunches of times mostly on oranges
but okay I have a I have a little
problem with that because you see I'm
not an
orange ow ow Jack there's a th000 people
here he's not going to talk to you Alex
my birthday I'm 100 years old talk to me
hi what's your name hi oh my God El
roer I don't know if you recognize me
but uh my name is Jack McFarland and I
do a oneman show everyone night at the
duplex called Just Jack additional info
on my website at www.just.colorado.org
you're aware but on this week's episode
of Along Came you there was supposed to
be a kiss and there wasn't well you know
Jack sometimes a kiss is just not a kiss
do we have any anniversary wait back to
Jack uh we went to complain and this
closet case upstairs cute in an offbeat
way got his number totally gave us the
brush off and I just want to know how
long I'm going to have to wait until I
can see two gay men kiss on network
television not as long as you'd
[Applause]
think oh my Lord not your boyfriend my
ass give me my freaking paper you hairy
little
th you think you're going to get away
with this but you're not I'm on to you
your history is over oh God get away
from
me
guys what is wrong with
you all right let me ask you you said
that you wanted mirrored
floors I'm not sure I can make that work
but when I'm doing jumping jacks I like
to look at
my yeah M Mir mirrors are bad bad I I'll
just look at my reflection in a steak
Knife if I had one which I don't there
are't no knives in
here what's going on gee honey you look
real pretty
today maybe sometime I could borrow your
little kitty
[Laughter]
[Applause]
shirt okay you guys are creeping me out
so I'm just G to ter
[Laughter]
get all right I'm just going to go and
work on my sketches and then I'm going
oh that's my datebook I thought that
will took it to work with him I was
going to kill
him but you have it now so no one has to
die
right
okay
[Applause]
Aon this may come as a great shock to
you but I'm a homeless
[Laughter]
sexual that's
it what's your next bombshell Harvey
Weinstein isn't always a perfect
gentleman that's it I'm gay does the
Hustler posing as your business
associate know he
suspects Karen I need you to help me
come out to my wife Crystal tonight
would be a good night to tell her but
it's her n th birthday and I'm afraid
the shock might kill
her come to think of it tonight might be
the perfect night to tell her he could
be a new daughter for all I care this is
great for me great better him than me
that's right better him than
[Music]
me raining down as cold
as sh
face through window cry in the night the
night goes morning just another
day Happy People Press my
way looking in their eyes I see a memory
I never realiz how happy you made me all
love are you C you g without
taking but I sent you away
[Music]
[Applause]
all you're using way too much of that o
it
tingles be careful you're getting it on
your lips don't lick it off would you
relax it's
fine that's so that's so we it's like
overuse may cause extreme facial
numbness how long do they
last what how long does it
last oh how long does it last uh 4 hours
why I had to call
tonight
what I had to IOP a stand
T
what I have to call oh you have to call
a Stefon at 7 tonight well that's 1 a.m.
in Spain you sure he didn't mean 7 his
time cuz that's right
now oh
my finger not work my finger don't
work contact with fingers and other
sensitive areas may cause an unwanted
reaction that's good advice for your
love life too well I got the way it goes
on in case of contact with tongue eating
a banana May reverse the effects
really oh look C I need a
[Laughter]
[Applause]
banana
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what you son of a
bit oh wait honey I think you're caught
on my bro oh I got it okay there you go
oh my gosh his art is
amazing look at
that oh my
God
will what are you doing I think You'
sprung a leak what are you talking
[Applause]
about I haven't been with a woman in
some time but I'm pretty sure they're
not supposed to do
that oh my God good Lord why don't you
two get a
room
please stop staring yes it's
share okay that's it nothing for us but
this Shar thing is out of control we're
going what's the problem you made us
wait for an hour for a table for
four in the back so she wouldn't be
gawked
at okay
by-bye freak hey you're the
freaks you know dude it is a little
weird that you're talking to my
doll um I don't think I need a drag
queen to Define normal
[Applause]
behavior but I will say this the look is
Flawless
whatever ooh working the
attitude okay you're
good I had a lot of
practice hey hey hey you're not that
great Mr
[Applause]
sister all right I do a better share
than
you you think
so actually it's you think so
[Applause]
ho are you kidding me with
this okay the hand is perfect but it's
more are you kidding me with this
[Applause]
hoe get a
life If I Could Turn Back
Time
[Applause]
and I turn
back snap out of
it